- Hello everyone, and welcome.
I'm Jacqueline Goldsby, I'm Chair
of the African-American
Studies Department,
and I'm really, really
excited to see so many of you
here in our Zoom room
for our final session
of the Department's colloquium series
which we call "Endeavors".
And this semester we've
been devoting our thinking
to the idea, the theme of "Black Now:
Conversations for the Revolution".
I wanna say a little bit
about where we've been so far
to kind of frame where
we're going to land today,
and also to give thanks
to the people, the staff,
who've organized us for
these past three months.
So, over these three months,
we've been able to engage
the vital issues facing Black Americans,
and indeed all Americans,
as we've braced ourselves
through a time unlike any other, right?
In the context of a global pandemic
and a presidential election
that tested the limits
of American democracy itself,
the stakes of what it means
to secure voting rights
and the turn-backs voter suppression
could never have been higher than now.
The stakes of organizing
healthcare delivery
as a right and practice for
justice couldn't be higher
than they are right now.
And the stakes of producing art
that could sustain critical
hope in beloved community
couldn't be higher than now.
And the stakes of devising policies
and activist programs that could dismantle
the carceral state, its
agencies, its agents
and the culture that sustains it
so that Black lives could thrive
and matter at the same time.
All of these issues have been absolutely
at the forefront of our thinking this term
and we've been very fortunate
to have a series of activists,
artists, and scholars come and talk to us
about these very issues.
And so I wanna thank
those who have been in the
Zoom room before today,
Latasha Brown, Amy Cox,
Emily Wang, Dwayne Betts,
Titus Kaphar, Claudia
Rankin, Phillip Golf,
Phillip Mackerras, and today's speakers
who will be introduced to you
in just a few minutes, seconds really,
I wanna thank them all
for sharing their wisdom,
sharing their work, doing the work,
and giving us the challenge
of asking ourselves what is to be done
and what can we do to
advance the cause of justice?
If you wanna see these
talks, we've posted them,
and this is why you're
being recorded today,
you can access these earlier discussions
on the African-American
Studies Department's website
go to the Videos tab,
and you can learn a lot
about what we've been thinking
about this past semester.
I wanna thank the staff
that's helped us organize
these conversations.
I, first of all, want to
thank our co-sponsors,
the Center for the Study
of Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration,
the directors, Professor Stephen Pitti,
and the Assistant Director Matthew Tanico
have been absolutely
brilliant and wonderful
in supporting us to organize this series,
including the whole process
of getting the videos mounted
through Yale's YouTube channel.
I never knew how much work that entailed,
and Steven and Matthew had
been really supportive in that.
Vanessa Epps, our newest staff member
in the African-American Studies Department
has been a tireless PR
engine for this series,
and I really wanna thank her
for her work in getting the word out.
I wanna thank Immanuel Bissell
who's been our technical
support these last three months
and making sure that the
Zoom room runs efficiently
and that no connections are
dropped, it's been amazing.
And last, but certainly not least,
I wanna thank Professor Crystal Feimster
whose absolute acute intelligence has,
she's curated the series with
a kind of verve and insight
and energy and care that has
really, really been remarkable.
I've learned so much because of her.
So, I just wanna thank (clapping) Crystal
and the staff for all their work.
So with that, I will turn it
over to Professor Feimster
who'll introduce our guests today.
- Thank you so much, Jackie, as always
for bringing us into the
space with such profound words
and acknowledgement of the work that we do
and the work that still needs
to be done in these days
where everybody is thinking
about the fragility of Black life.
I wanted to add my thanks to yours.
I'm not gonna name everybody that you did,
but I do wanna, again, thank Vanessa Epps
who has been my right
hand in this whole process
of bringing everybody together
in this "Endeavor" series.
Moreover, I wanna thank
all of my colleagues.
None of this would have been possible
without folks agreeing to show up
and to show out in many ways,
whether as interlocutors
for the conversations or as the keynote.
And so, I wanna thank
everybody for their part
in making this happen.
On that note, I do wanna get us started.
We have a little bit of time here
and we wanna make the most
of it, and I wanna just,
for those of you who
are new to the format,
I'm just gonna sort of
reiterate what the format is
before I introduce our
three speakers today.
We, as professor Goldsby
mentioned, we are recording these
and we really wanna try
to keep as many people
out of the frame as possible,
besides our speakers.
And so, we will start
with our interlocutor,
Gwen Prowse will kick us off.
At 12:45, we will open up for Q&A,
but we do it in the Zoom way.
And we will ask that
you send your questions
to Gwen Prowse in the private chat,
she will curate the Q&A
and make sure that all your
questions are addressed.
And I know what they will
be answered brilliantly
by Elizabeth and Tracey.
I will remind you in the chat,
"Oh, we've reached that time,
so please send in your questions to Gwen,"
and then Gwen will present
those to the presenters.
We end at 1:15, so we won't
be holding people over.
So on that note, let me began
by introducing some of my favorite people,
friends and colleagues.
Tracey Meares, first,
who I've known since
the day I arrived here,
and has welcomed me
into the community of
scholars here at Yale,
and my family into the
community of New Haven,
and I'll always be grateful for that.
Tracey Meares is the Walton
Hale Hamilton Professor
and Founding Director of
the Justice Collaboratory
at Yale Law School.
Before joining Yale, she was a professor
at the University of Chicago
Law School from 1995 to 2007.
She was the first African-American woman
granted tenure at both law schools.
Meares is nationally recognized expert
on policing and urban communities.
She has worked extensively
with the federal government
including being a member
of President Barack Obama's Task Force
on 21st Century Policing.
In 2019, Meares was elected a member
of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
My colleague Elizabeth Hinton
is an associate professor
in the Department of History
and the Department of
African-American Studies at Yale.
And I hope like Tracey welcomed me,
I hope that I'll be a
person who can help you
and your family adjust to life
in New Haven in the post-COVID moment,
it's just been so hard at this time,
but I hope you know that the Department
and all of us are really
pleased to have you among us,
and can't wait to sort
of meet your daughter
and hanging out over drinks in person.
So, Hinton's research focuses
on the persistence of poverty,
racial inequality, and urban violence
in the 21st century United States.
She is considered one of
the nation's leading experts
on criminalization and policing.
In her book, "From the War on
Poverty to the War on Crime:
The Making of Mass
Incarceration in America",
published by Harvard University Press,
Hinton examines the implementations
of federal law enforcement programs
beginning in the mid 1960s
that transformed the
domestic social policies
and laid the groundwork
for the expansion of
the U.S. prison system.
And my students read about three chapters
of "From the War on Poverty"
in my Long Civil Rights Course this year,
and it really made a
difference kind of changing
the way that I organize that
course and the way it is.
And so I am particularly
grateful for that work,
so thank you, Elizabeth.
I've also finally but not least,
had to introduce Gwen Prowse
who is one of our amazing PhD candidates
in the Political Science
and African-American Studies Department.
Gwen has become one of those people
that I often call on to do extra work
no matter what kind of series
or workshop I'm working with.
I always think of her and her work,
the kind of intersectional
work that she's doing,
interdisciplinary work that she's doing.
And so, I'm especially grateful
because I think this is the second request
that I've made of her to participate
in one of the workshops or series
that I've been a part of this year.
So, (mutters) my gratitude to you, Gwen.
Gwen, the focus of her research
is grassroots political
mobilization in U.S. cities.
Her work in multi-methods
and aims to involve community members
in every step of the research process.
She is a research fellow
with the Institute
for Social Policy Studies and an affiliate
with the Justice Collaboratory
at the Yale Law School.
She is a Co-PI with Vesla Weaver
and Tracey Meares for the
Portals Policing Project
which examines how police
and citizens' interactions
shape political knowledge
and political discourse
in majority Black communities
in the United States.
Thank you all. And I'm
gonna turn it over to Gwen.
- Thank you so much, Professor Feimster.
Can everyone hear me? Okay, great.
Thank you, Professor Feimster
and thank you Professor Goldsby,
Vanessa Epps, and our partners at RITM.
I'm deeply honored to be
moderating today's discussion
between two scholars who I admire so much.
That we're ending this
semester's "Endeavor" series
in conversation with Professor Meares
and Professor Hinton could
not be more appropriate.
Professor Meares is the Co-founder
of the Justice Collaboratory.
Four out of the six speakers
of this semester's series
are active members of
this group, Dwayne Betts,
Doctor Emily Wang, Professor
Phillip Atiba Goff,
and of course Professor Hinton.
Together, Collaboratory
members demonstrate how health,
safety, art and education,
and the many ways in which
they intersect and overlap,
are foundational to a future
where Black freedom is possible,
where a third reconstruction
is on its way.
From their standpoints and expertise,
they name that the steps on
the way toward revolution
are both complicated and
absolutely necessary and urgent.
They don't just study these ideas,
they push them toward policy.
Many demand that those
most intimately affected
by the carceral state
participate and lead.
Meanwhile, Professor Hinton's work
as a 20th century historian reminds us
that this type of work is not new,
that reckonings have happened before
and in the not too distant past,
that wave of democratization in the U.S.
have coincided the growth in surveillance,
punishment and control of Black
and indigenous peoples and migrants.
In her articles, books, and op-eds,
Professor Hinton reminds us
that the bold recommendations
of the Kerner Commission in 1968,
following the wave of urban rebellions
in response to police violence,
she reminds us how the
fear of white racism,
quote, "Fomenting domestic turmoil
led to liberal policymakers
distancing themselves
from these very recommendations."
This may sound tragically
familiar to discourse today,
but today I'm so excited to
talk to these two scholars
and bring them in
conversation with one another,
for all of the tireless work they're doing
to reverse that course of history,
in collaboration with others,
community, and many scholars.
So I'm gonna begin first with the topic
of the Justice Collaboratory
and if Professor Meares
you'd like to begin,
just to talk a little bit
about the Collaboratory, its genesis,
and then Professor Hinton, if
you would like to talk a bit
about the work that you've
come to do within that space.
- Unmute, it only took nine months
to figure out how to do that
at the beginning before one speaks, right?
Thanks so much for the
introduction, for having us,
and for the opportunity
to be among friends
at the end of the semester.
Also, that 56 of you turned out
on what is essentially close
to the last day of the semester
is pretty impressive, so thanks for that.
The Collaboratory's origin
is a social science research project,
essentially a collaboration
between the Center for Policing Equity.
I think I saw Philip Atiba Goff
somewhere in this Zoom room,
and when he was at UCLA,
and some folks at John Jay came together
to put together a demonstration project
that was funded by the
Department of Justice
to bring together our
various research streams
and come up with some policy approaches
to see if we could make
some kind of a difference.
It wasn't an attempt to
fundamentally reconceive safety
as we understand it should happen,
but certainly an opportunity
to bring science to policy
which is an important thing
that the Collaboratory has stood for,
as I think many have noted,
and many members of the
Collaboratory have noted
that too often, policy has no theory
and certainly has very little evidence.
And we like to proceed from the standpoint
that evidence is a set of facts
that are offered in answer to a question,
and one doesn't know what questions to ask
unless one is actually
appropriately guided by theory.
What works is not a real question, right?
So, that was the beginning.
And with those initial resources,
we were able to put together
and attract a group of incredible
people who are interested
in working on this
project broadly conceived.
And so today, I would say
we're much more forward-looking
in terms of not just thinking
about in an emergency
context and extremists
what are some things one
could do in policy terms
to make existing organization
systems, and the like,
less harmful, but trying
to work out much more thick
and broad theory of what
broad community vitality means
and how that is centered
around concepts of justice.
And the last thing I'll say
as I don't wanna go on blah, blah, blah,
but once you take seriously
the idea of community vitality
as a goal, then one understands
that one must center
the people whose safety
demands are relevant
to said policy, right?
And it seems like a really simple thing,
an obvious thing to do, but
as we've seen historically
as I'm sure Elizabeth will discuss,
those constant effort to
doing that have been derailed,
and I think it's our hope
that we can try once again,
to deepen, and center, and provide
a more robust multidisciplinary
theoretical framework
around that approach.
- Before I talk about the Collaboratory,
I also wanna think Crystal and Gwen
for those really tremendous
introductions, thank you.
Thank all of you for
coming, and of course,
it's an honor to be in
conversation with Tracey.
I'm really looking forward to it.
And this also is kind of like
my first big public appearance
as a Yale faculty member, which
is really exciting for me.
I just arrived here in the summer,
but I've been on leave this term
madly finishing up a book manuscript
which maybe I'll talk about some later,
and excited to be fully on next term
and begin teaching here.
And so, I'm just excited
for this because it's part
of my kind of like welcome
into the community,
so, thank you.
So actually, I mean, a big
pull for me coming to Yale
was to be a part of the
Justice Collaboratory,
and of course the African-American
Studies Department
and in conversations with scholars
whose work I really admire,
but what the Justice Collaboratory
has increasingly done,
I think, too, with the
addition of of Phil Goff,
as Tracey mentioned, is
really bringing together
an interdisciplinary group of scholars
who is attempting to tackle
and make meaningful changes
in the kind of landscape of safety
and criminal justice today.
And I think the community-centered
model through which
much of the Justice
Collaboratory's work is done
is really inspirational to me,
and I think what is going
to be key if we are to,
as Jackie mentioned at the outset,
dismantle the carceral state
and institutions which
have really functioned
as the engine of racial
inequality, post-Civil Rights.
I'm kind of coming in
hitting the ground running,
in some senses, because I'm
working with Dwayne Betts
who you heard from earlier
this term, the amazing poet
and legal scholar who,
and this is totally Dwayne's
brainchild and idea,
and I'm just kind of here supporting him,
but he is directing the
Million Books Project,
which will institute 500 book capsules
into prisons and juvenile
detention facilities
across the United States and Puerto Rico.
And this is an incredibly
ambitious project, right,
because it's seeking to
give prisoners access
to an entirely different
set of reading materials
and educational materials
that they don't have access to
in the sense that most prison libraries,
it's like full of like Tom Clancy novels
and really, really outdated
pieces of literature.
And so, Dwayne is going
to really transform
the kind of landscape of what
the kinds of reading materials
that prisoners have access to
when it's a combination of the 500 books,
we're still in the process
of choosing what they're going to be.
And this actually has been,
the project launched this summer.
And it's a big task to figure
out like what 500 books
we think kind of like best represent
what needs to be in prisons
across the United States today.
So we're still finalizing the list,
actually, I'm meeting with
Dwayne right after this
to talk about that.
But it's a combination of
literature, and history,
and political science, and sociology,
that will really provide
a new kind of robust
curriculum inside prisons,
and in itself as a kind
of established library,
we hope that it'll help foster discussion
and community organizing and
mobilization inside prisons.
And so far, we don't have
the 500 books finalized,
but in just a few months,
we've already got several thousand books
into 80 different prisons
in 30 different states.
So, already this project is
making a humongous difference
in the lives of people
who are incarcerated
in the middle of the COVID-19 pandemic,
which is literally wreaking havoc
inside the nation's prison system.
And just one last plug on
that, Dwayne and also Hardy,
who actually was a student of mine,
is a PhD student of mine at
Harvard, I'm her advisor,
who is now a first-year
student at Yale Law School,
Elsa and Dwayne are hosting a podcast
featuring authors who are
included in the collection,
and this podcast will be
available to the public,
but it will also be
available inside prisons.
So, look out for that.
And this is just one example,
to mention the last thing,
that the Justice Collaboratory
house the Million Books Project,
but it was made possible
by a humongous $5 million grant
from the Mellon Foundation.
And so, this is just one
example of the kinds of programs
that the Justice Collaboratory supports
and the kinds of real difference
the Collaboratory is making
in terms of the landscape of incarceration
and also policing and public safety
and community vitality,
as Tracey mentioned.
- Thank you so much to you
both for providing an overview
of the origin of the Justice Collaboratory
and also one of the specific
and crucial projects
that's taking place right now.
Tracey, you said earlier if
community vitality is the goal,
one must center the people
whose safety demands
are relevant to policy.
Can you talk a little bit
about what that looks like
in research or within the Collaboratory?
So, what does it mean to center
those whose safety demands
are most relevant to policy
in social science research,
or legal research,
and perhaps, Elizabeth in the archive?
- So, let me give you two examples
of how you might go about doing it
and then let me say something
about what it's not,
about what I don't know
yet, (chuckles) okay?
So Point One, how you do it.
The first example I would
point to is our own project,
Ms. Prowse, which is the
Portals Policing Project.
If you google portalspolicingproject.com,
you can actually see what we've done.
We've again, taken an art project,
actually, it's an art installation
promoted by Shared_Studios
where people are able to connect
with one another through some
pretty sophisticated tech.
So think full-body Zoom in
a golden shipping container
where members of communities
that we tried to identify,
some that where people experience
higher than what is
average, we'll call it,
impacts of violence, whether we're talking
about interpersonal violence
or police violence, right,
and ask them about their
experience with both violence
and police and the state's response to it.
Generally, by listening
to those conversations,
one can easily ascertain
that what I would call
stakeholders, right,
people who experienced both the problems
that the state typically sends
general purpose armed first
responders to address,
how they deal with both those problems
and the state response,
and their own conception
of what they think the
state's response should be.
Understand importantly,
that their own conception
of what the state's response should be
isn't necessarily a conversation
about how the policing
service as we know it
could and should be different,
although there is some of that,
it's literally a conversation
about what the state's response should be.
And then a lot of the
work that I'm doing myself
which is relevant to my Point
Three, I don't know yet,
is thinking very seriously
about a set of public goods,
the state's provision of public goods,
what the police power
means in that context,
and that is a term of art, everyone.
So, police power in law is
not the policing service
as we know it, the police
power is the state's ability
to regulate and support health order,
and such, for its citizens.
So, any state response to
the pandemic right now,
like vaccinations or
more generally requiring
that people go to public
schools, for example,
and get a certain level of education,
that's actually an exercise
of the police power.
We can come back to that
later, but in any case,
that's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is to
invest really heavily in what,
the term of art is CBPR,
it's Community-Based
Approaches to Research
where you actually
design research projects
in collaboration with the
members of the communities
with whom you're working and studying.
That's much more common in medicine,
although even in medicine that
is on the fringe, frankly.
Emily Wang does a lot of this work
who is also a Collaboratory member.
Elizabeth and I are actually
partnering with Emily right now
on a project concerning COVID detections
in incarceration settings,
as well as developing
protocols for vaccination
and who gets vaccinations first
by actually, again, centering
people who are affected,
people who are in the
incarcerated settings.
that's a CBPR approach.
One of the things that we're
very interested in doing
in the Collaboratory is
doing more of that work,
CBPR approaches on the
social science side.
It's a difficult to do
because foundations don't
typically pay for it, right,
and so, trying to figure out
how to design those kinds
of things are difficult.
So, that's one answer, how.
What it's not, what it's not is thinking
about a top-down approach to, for example,
when you think about safety saying,
"Well, homicide rates are high.
The best way to approach homicide rates
are sending more police
armed first responders
to dealing with it."
This is what Mayor Bloomberg
and Ray Kelly did in New York.
And you should be grateful
that fewer people are being killed
because we have decided
what the best approach is.
Or to put it differently, I'll
use a kind of outside example
think about online
interaction, social media,
the Justice Collaboratory also
has a whole thing that we do
in the social media space actually.
And that approach would be to say
that the best way to have health on
and the social media is just to focus
on content moderation and rule violations
rather than to take an approach
where you could seriously think through
the architecture of interaction
that people have in that space,
and think about it in
a helpful way, right?
Don't ban cars because cars are dangerous,
figure out how to have better
lighting on the streets,
have rumble strips on streets,
take curves out of roads, right,
so that people can have egress
in a more helpful way, right?
That's two ways of thinking about it.
Here's what I don't know, Point Three,
we started out talking about
a more robust theory of community vitality
which I think is a center
part of achieving justice
because so many people have been involved
so long in the negative project,
figuring out articulations
of a theoretical approach to
that other than something like
everybody should have equal capacity
to fulfill their goals and projects.
That's a goal, but it's sort
of not like a robust theory
of how to do it, what it
means, how you'd study it,
that's the part I don't know.
And so, one small thing I'm
doing is to think about,
for example, the police
power and recover that
as something that's positive,
that citizens deserve,
that citizens deserve to have
their state working for them
and providing a set of
public goods for flourishing.
- Yeah, just continuing,
I mean, some of the
issues that Tracey raised,
I mean I think so much
of it has to do with
the voices that we choose
to privilege and center.
And I think that goes into the ways
that we read the archive.
And it's really difficult,
the archive does not often capture
the most marginalized
and oppressed voices.
And I think especially
when it comes to policing
and crime control in
low-income communities of color
in the late 20th and early 21st century,
it's really difficult, which
is part of the reason why
a lot of the interpretation that we have
that is based in archival sources,
does tend to privilege a narrative
that talks about the
demands for law and order,
tougher sentencing, more
police that were emerging
from communities that were over-policed,
especially by the time
we get to the war on drugs in the 1980s.
But I think there is a
different way to read that
and to read the sets of
demands that people are making
in the Portal's Project,
but also in the 1960s.
But the projects that
I'm working on right now
considers Black rebellion
from the mid '60s really to the present.
And especially in the kind
of the late '60s, early '70s,
'68 to '72 period that we
don't really think about,
and my kind of primary
source space for this work
are newspapers, archival
records of radical civil rights
and Black power organizations
that were working on anti-police
issues and oral histories.
And there are, even within
the newspapers, right,
if you privilege the voices
and perspectives of those
people who participated
who resorted to political violence
in order to make a set
of demands on the state,
if you privilege their
perspectives and their demands
and actually take seriously when they say,
"We don't wanna live in shacks anymore.
We don't want rats and
roaches in our apartments.
We want new kinds of
investment. We want jobs.
The kids don't have summer
jobs in our communities."
These are the demands
that people were making
and an incident of police violence
ended up usually being the
precipitating incident.
So, very often we kind of
focus on the material results
instead of actually centering the people
who are in the ground zero
of where these repressive
measures are implemented.
So, I think a lot of
it has to do with like
who we choose to privilege
and how seriously we take the demands
of people who are living
in communities that are over-policed,
and under-protected and under-resourced.
And I think because of the position
of many of the people
living in these communities
they're often not really listened to,
and as Tracey mentioned, the response,
the immediate knee-jerk response
historically ends up being more police.
And this gets into something that,
an idea that I've developed
with just the Collaboratory member
and former Yale professor
who's now at Johns Hopkins, Vesla Weaver
and Julie Kohler-Hausmann,
who's a historian at Cornell,
that's called Selective Hearing.
And we wrote an op-ed in "The
New York Times" about this.
And one of the things that
we argue is that like,
we ask the question, like,
"Why is it that despite
like all of the demands
that Black people make on the
state, like the only demand
that gets consistently
taken up is like policing,
sentencing and prisons, et cetera?"
And so, we called this
concept selective hearing
because when Black communities are saying,
"We want better policing,"
what Tracey's talking about,
like, "we want protection, we
want the state to work for us,
we want control over what public safety
in our communities look like,"
instead of like actually
giving that, right,
what policymakers, and politicians,
and law enforcement officials hear is,
"Okay, better policing
that means more policing."
So again, it's like this
selective hearing concept.
And I think one of the key challenges,
and it is really a challenge,
I think a lot of the responses
to the protest this summer
and the kind of the robust
national discussions
about police brutality that emerged,
really shows is that selected
hearing is still going on
and people are still
not being listened to.
And we're at a moment
when, in order to achieve
the kind of community vitality
that Tracey's talking about,
these perspectives really, really need
to ground any kind of
change moving forward.
- Thank you so much for those responses.
And I think this point
about selective hearing
in the policymaking process
leads me to ask another
question that I wanted to bring
to both of you today, which
is, both of you have served
in various kind of policymaking
public capacities outside,
using your work as scholars
to inform the policy-making
process at the local level,
and at the national level.
I know Tracey you've served
on the President's Task Force
on 21st Century Policing,
you're now on the Board
of Police Commissioners in
New Haven, and then Elizabeth,
I understand you've done some
work in Stockton, California.
So something that I'd love
to hear from both of you,
and maybe Elizabeth you'd
like to start first,
what have you learned about institutions
in the process of serving
in these roles, and how,
yeah, how have you been able to contribute
your work as a scholar
but also how has these
experiences maybe complicated
or frustrated what you know
about the state through your research?
- That's a great question.
I'm glad I'm going first
'cause I wanna know
what Tracey's response
to what I have to say.
So, yeah, as Gwen
mentioned, I've been working
for the past, wow, it's
been four years now
with the Police Chief of
Stockton, California, Eric Jones,
who's one of the most, if not
the most progressive chiefs
in the country, he was, it's now over,
was part of this program
called National Initiative
for Safe Communities which started like
kind of as a post-Ferguson thing
out of the Department of Justice
to really implement procedural justice,
Tracey's kind of model for Policing
in the 21st Century in
six pilot departments,
and Stockton was chosen as one of them.
And I was hooked up with Chief Jones
because he was open to using history
as part of what he was calling
a racial reconciliation effort
between the police department
and residents of color in Stockton.
And he basically said, "You
can have access to our records
in order to help us better understand
the history of kind of
racialized enforcement,
and so that we can use
this historical evidence
to ground our discussions moving forward."
Stockton's Department
also had a really robust
procedural justice training
set up and especially a module
within that training that spent
a day looking at the history
of racist law enforcement,
which at least to my knowledge,
the amount of time spent
on looking at kind of the
history of police oppression
of Black and Brown communities
is really kind of unmatched.
They do a day-long training
that goes from slavery
and the Black codes, all the
way up to the modern day,
and a lot of this
information is completely new
for most of the police officers.
So, part of my task was to
talk to people in the community
and scour these records to kind
of uncover various incidents
that could be put at the
center of the training,
but also in the listening
sessions that were being held
between police officers
and community members.
And the idea was, in
part, because a lot of
the kind of like the
History Module training
was focused on like police
complicity and lynchings,
and other forms of racial terrorism
that seemed, for many officers,
very far away from Stockton.
And so this process is ongoing,
but it has been, I think,
something that's been
really incredible to see
and even the effort for
these officers to reckon
with this history, I
think is really important
and a step towards
improving general relations
with the community and improving trust
which is one of the kind of big principles
of procedural justice.
I think Stockton, in some ways,
there are a number of problems, right?
I mean, one is that even
if police administrators
buy in to these kinds of discussions
and the idea of racial reconciliation,
if you wanna call it that,
there is a disconnect
between the administrators
like Chief Jones
and Scott Meadors, who does
the History Module training
and the rank-and-file officers.
What's required is a
humongous cultural shift
to get rank-and-file to really buy in
and to really begin to change the ways
in which they patrol
targeted Mexican-American
and Black communities in Stockton.
And it's also as part of that work too,
last year, I was a instructor
in the California Command College
where basically police
administrators go to,
they do a several-month-long
intensive educational emergent experience.
And so, I came in one day to
talk about racism and policing
and it was a really, for me,
a really like intense and
informative experience
and I realized then that, like so many,
even in this moment when,
and it's not just chief Jones,
right, you have former heads
of the International
Association of Chief of Police
and police chiefs around the
country beginning to apologize
for things like lynching
and beginning to say,
"We need to listen to
community in new ways.
We need to reckon with the
history of police violence
especially directed
against people of color."
Again, a lot of other administrators,
a lot of rank-and-file
think it's complete BS,
they think it actually prevents them
from being able to do their jobs,
they think that, in many senses,
like any kind of police reform,
especially one that is kind of centered
in notions of racial
justice, doesn't allow them
to perform their duties as
police officers, as they see fit.
So, on the one hand, I go to Stockton
and we have a great listening session
or there's a really powerful training,
and I'm feeling like, "Okay,
this is like planting the seeds of change,
it's not necessarily the end of itself."
And then, like, I go down to
San Diego to do this training
and I'm hearing a bunch of
other police administrators say,
"This is complete BS
and we can't do our jobs
because we're scared
of being called racist
and knowing this history
doesn't help us do police
work in the present."
So, we still have a very
long way to go. (chuckles)
- It's funny you said you wanted
to hear what I had to say.
I mean, I'm like, "Well,
welcome to my life."
(Tracey and Elizabeth laughing)
What have I been doing for
the last decade, I mean?
I think being a lawyer makes it easier
for me to sit with that disjuncture
because I have my theoretical goals,
I have the stuff that
I do in the day to day
to both just make what exists less harmful
because we're an extremist,
but also like you said, inch forward.
But also I think being a lawyer,
I have a really much more detailed sense
of all the ways in which it's hard
which are not just about
people's psychology,
not just about the ways in
which organizational forums
cause people as a psychological matter
to just sort of like try
to get through their day.
Like, part of what you're talking about
when people say, "This doesn't
make my job any easier,"
is just the day-to-day, most
people in their day-to-day
just want their day to
be as easy as possible.
It's the status quo and
they're not actually trying
to challenge themselves and change.
And I'm not saying that in a negative way,
I'm just being descriptive, right?
For most people, they don't wanna get up
and be like, "What's the
hardest thing I can do today?"
That's just not what people do, right?
And then you add to that
the way government works in this country,
federalism is a huge issue.
I'm sure most educated
people are just aware of it,
but when you actually do not study it,
you don't understand the complexities
that that governmental
arrangement gives you, okay?
So, I've done the federal
president's task force,
I also just got off of a statewide force
to think about how post
should change its training
for the new Connecticut
Use of Force Statute
which has its own
federalism issues given that
there are a gazillion tiny
little cities in this state
and no regional government,
and like managing those
people to raise them
to a basic floor is very difficult.
And on Tuesday night, I sat
for two hours as a commissioner
on the New Haven Board
of Police Commissioners
where we had a discussion
about the relationship
between the New Haven Police Department
and Yale's Police Department,
which, of course, is
intimately tied up in the fact
that this university doesn't
have to pay state taxes
and that the city is under-resourced,
and so, how you think
about delivering safety
to people in this city who are right now,
how many times have I
used the word extremists?
The homicide rate today in New Haven
is double this year what it was last year.
Shootings are up by 85%, okay?
So, in a context like that
when people are saying
to folks in the city,
"Take away the one
thing that you believe,"
I'm not saying they're right,
it's like what they believe,
the one thing that you
believe is making you safer,
that is reduce the number
of Yale police officers
who can enforce the law
when people in this community
think that makes them safer,
and in some cases, I think they're right.
When the Yale police
department handles 20,000 calls
for service per year, that the
New Haven Police Department
would otherwise have to handle
and doesn't have the resources,
it's a complex issue,
it's just really complex.
And so, there are no easy answers here.
Let me give you one more example
of the ways in which federalism works.
In Minneapolis, for example,
there's currently a proposal
to take away somewhere between
7 million or $8 million
of the police budget and devote
it to other things, right?
One of the calls is, "Well,
let's take $8 million
of the police budget and
give it to mental health."
Okay, fine.
Guess what, in Minneapolis,
mental health services are
provided at the county level,
which is a different tax structure.
So, it is not just the case
that you're gonna take
money from the city budget
and give it to the county, in
fact, everybody understands
that that's not what's gonna happen.
And so then the idea is,
well, let's just build out
the city's public health
service to do more of this work.
Well, okay, maybe, but
like, why would you do that
when the county is already doing this
and $8 million isn't
enough to provide, right?
So, this ish is really hard, (bangs table)
and it is a mistake to
underestimate how hard it is.
That doesn't mean that we
shouldn't be working on it,
like, can I show you my
gray hair, (chuckles)
but like, it takes a lot.
It's not just about a theory,
and it's not just about asking communities
what they need and want,
which I do think is the first step, right?
There's all of that, and then
there's the governance problem
which is prodigious.
- Thank you both for those answers.
As a political scientist,
the governance problem
is something that I unfortunately
think about a lot, too.
Speaking of conversations
that are happening
at the community level,
and this question of what do
we do with the city budgets,
state, county, federal
budgets, to keep people safe,
I'm gonna have my last question
before I bring in other
voices from this group,
be about your article in "The Atlantic"
with Tom Tyler, Tracey.
I'm gonna read a quote real
quick from this article.
So, you say, "If America is to move
beyond its troubled and
conflict-laden relationship
with its police, it must have
a broader, serious discussion
about what democratic
policing can and should be.
What are police for?
This is a moment for such a discussion.
The crime rate has for several years now
been at historically low levels,
the cost of police community
conflict are once again clear,
and in an era of shrinking
municipal budgets,
the costs of America's
current style of policing
have major effects on the
ability of communities
to provide other necessary public goods
that are building blocks of vitality.
For this discussion to be successful,
it must involve the
meaningful participation
of all people in America's communities."
So this question of what
is it police are for,
I'd like for both of you
to reflect on kind of
how you are currently pursuing
answers to that question.
What might be your answer today,
or to whom are you like
most inspired as a voice,
as a voice or a set of voices
who are engaging this question
of what is it police are for?
- Elizabeth, do you wanna go first?
- So, I mean, I think police,
as we think about police,
and as we think about police historically
have been agents of social control
and defenders of racial
hierarchy and oppression.
So, I mean that, from
the early kind of forms
and slave patrols, the present,
the kind of function of police,
at least as far as poor people
go and people of color go,
have been historically focused
more on kind of like apprehension
and identifying suspects to
remove from the community
than necessarily protecting people.
In white and middle-class communities
especially in the 20th century, right,
police functions have been primarily
about protecting property.
So, policing in low-income
communities of color
is completely different than it is
in middle-class communities
and white communities,
and so, in that sense,
policing needs to end as we know it.
I mean, I do think that
public safety is important,
we need to have a public safety function,
but after studying this history,
and also centering how
residents themselves think
about public safety
and the various reforms
that had been suggested historically
that policing doesn't know,
that police officer
doesn't necessarily look
like an outsider who
comes into a community
who is fearful of the community
and who then in turn the
community is fearful of
in a uniform with a gun.
And so that model of public safety,
and I think, I mean, this
has been under discussion
for half a century now, at least.
But I mean, certainly, in recent years
with the kind of rise of the
slogan defund the police,
right, we're beginning
to rethink the logics
of that model of law enforcement.
And I mean, it just really briefly
on some of what Tracey touched
on at the end of her comment,
I mean, I think one way
to think about defund,
the way that it's framed
is something that's like
negative and taking away,
and that I think has done some harm
to the idea of reconstituting
public safety, as we know it.
And I think taxes are really important,
and one way that we can think
about how to begin to invest
in different models of public
safety and invest in education
and invest in decent housing
and invest in job creation
which may be the most important thing,
is to think about our tax structure.
Like, who gets the biggest welfare
in this country, corporations.
The richest people in this country
actually pay less taxes
than the middle class.
The entire tax structure makes no sense
in the United States,
and if we begin to at least reform that,
that's gonna free up billions of dollars
to begin to spend on public goods
in an entirely different
way than they have been.
I mean, our tax structure
has kind of like,
it's become more regressive
coinciding with the rise
of prisons in this country.
So the fact that we tax
the way we do in the U.S.,
I think is reflective of the fact
that we are this
mass-incarceration society.
And so what defund is
really about, for me,
is asking that question
of what are police for,
but also calling on government authorities
to make a different set of investments.
And I do think historically
the federal government has
played an important role
in kind of taking the lead
in ensuring various protections
for especially people who
are racially oppressed,
but also thinking about ways
that we could redistribute resources.
And so I think that it is going to take
a federal intervention for us to see
these kinds of national
changes and transformations
that are gonna be necessary
if we want to build a
more equitable society
and realize the promises
of our founding values
and the civil war
reconstruction amendments.
- So, I don't have a lot to
add to that other than to say,
just to remind everyone
this was not an articles,
it's an essay I wrote in "The Atlantic".
And the reason why it's important
to mention that is like,
you have to sort of try to convey a lot
in an economy of words.
So, there are a lot of ways
to read what are police for.
One is to do what Elizabeth did,
which is to say, "Well,
what have they been for?
What are they for right now?"
And I co-sign everything she just said.
Another way of thinking about
it is to be forward-looking,
and to say, when we were
asking that question,
"What are police for?" we're
talking about in the new era,
in the new vision, and in a place
we're really trying to think of safety
and then the provision of safety
by the state as a public good.
Well, what are police for in that world?
Understanding that police
might not look anything
like the policing service
that as it exists today.
When I'm asking what are police for,
I'm not asking what are
armed general purpose chained
first responders for,
although there might be a role
for some of those people
in some context, actually,
but when I'm talking about
democratic policing, I'd like to,
and I wrote that before
we'd, Gwen, finished our
piece on Protect and Serve,
and I've been writing
a bunch of things all summer about this.
It's important to distinguish
the police service
as it exists today, from
the concept of policing
as a public good, as an instantiation
of a fully realized reconstruction
of the police power.
And in that context,
I wanna use reconstruction
capital R, right?
Because if you take
a historical through-line in
all of this, the communities,
and I think the COVID pandemic
that we're living through
provides a very good example
that the communities that are
experiencing all the violence
that I just spoke of in New Haven,
as well as violence in
the police response,
are the same communities that
are experiencing higher rates
of COVID infection and
higher rates of death,
and higher rates of maternal, fetal death,
and higher rates of low
educational attainment,
and higher rates of lead
poisoning, we can go on,
which is a result of
decades of disinvestment
in these communities over time,
which we've known for a very long time,
but concretely, when the
Kerner Commission's report
was made public, right?
And we haven't done anything about that
which connects up with
what Elizabeth was saying
about the tax structure, right?
And so, in that context,
when I think about abolition,
and I wrote in 2017 in
the "Boston Review",
"Policing as we know it
must be abolished before
it can be transformed,"
it is useful to connect that conversation,
the abolition conversation
with reconstruction
and think about that aborted project,
a project that was supported
by white supremacist violence, right,
and think about that in the context
of where we started this conversation,
which is, what does it mean
to achieve community vitality, right?
To my mind, a reconstruction
project is necessary for that
and a reconstruction project
that not only centers community,
but acknowledges the
necessity of state support.
It's not a private
project, it's not private,
and people deserve the
support of the state.
They deserve it.
And I for one, am gonna be
spending the next 10 years
before I retire, and yes, I am
going to retire in 10 years,
(laughs) I'm gonna be fighting for that,
I'm gonna be fighting for that.
- Thank you, both.
And now I'm gonna turn over to
questions from the audience.
So, if you have any questions,
please send those my way.
Well, I'll start with
this question for Tracey
because you've touched upon it a bit more
but can you say more, this
is from Professor Goldsby,
about the governance problem?
What does that encompass,
and why is it prodigious?
And then kind of the second
part of that question is,
how might, quote, recovering
positive police power
rake the log jams that federalism
and/or governance create?
- Yeah, like that's such a long thing,
but let me just give you
a couple of examples,
just to say there's just not as much,
especially with respect to safety
as we think about it in
the policing context,
that can be done at the federal level,
as people think, right,
it's just not a thing
that can happen, right?
The federal government,
actually, because of
the way it's grown up,
has more ability to mandate
educational standards right now
than it does to create national standards
for how policing agencies should operate.
So, when you're trying
to figure out what to do,
you either use the federal government
to provide technical
assistance and resources
at the agency level, or you
try to figure out some way
to incentivize states to
mandate agencies to do it.
And that's a difficult project,
and we don't have a ton of time,
but like I can give you
very specific examples
of how to do that.
Like, I've proposed to
the current administration
like ways you can do it,
but it's hard and it requires
congressional approval
so that if you don't have
Democratic majorities
in both houses, it's hard to do.
You can't do it by executive order,
I mean, there are all these things
that are really tough to do.
So, when you talk about
the Positive Project,
the strategy that we have been adopting
for the last several years
has been to sort of think
about it agency by agency,
using demonstration projects,
using kind of natural competition
among these folks to be like,
"Oh, I wanna be like
Eric Jones in Stockton."
I mean, that only gets you so far.
You can try to work at the state level
to pass certain legislation
for minimum standards,
but legislators have to be motivated,
most state legislators are part part-time
and they're not experts,
they don't have staffs like
the federal government does,
and so, there's a different role
that organizations like let's
say the Justice Collaboratory
might be able to play in
producing model legislation
but then of course we can't lobby,
so how are we gonna get
the legislation passed?
Like, that's the kind
of stuff that I mean.
And I'm about to be
wonkity-wonk, wonk, wonk, wonk,
but it's a wonky-wonk problem,
it's a super wonky-wonk problem.
- Is there anything you'd like
to add to that, Elizabeth,
or can I follow up with another question?
Thank you, Tracey. Okay.
So this is an interdisciplinary
question for you, Elizabeth,
which is that if rank-and-file police
think that knowing history
doesn't help them do police work,
would learning something
like political science
be more effective in their work?
- Yeah, I think, unfortunately,
it's not about an aversion to history
but I think more about an aversion
to having discussions about racism
and having discussions about
the nature of inequality.
And so, whether we approach
that from a political science,
or a sociological, or
historical framework,
I think that that is primarily
what they are adverse to.
And this is not true
across the board, right,
but some of what I've heard is that,
and this is kind of a
more specific example
of what I was getting at, but,
because of the kind of emphasis
on systemic racism in police departments,
police have kind of like shied away
from the issue altogether
and have argued that like they have.
And this is part of some of what,
especially conservative pundits,
have used to explain the Ferguson Effect,
that basically like following uprising,
that police retreat
because they're worried
that if they make arrest
or if they do their jobs,
that they're gonna be called a racist
or that anything that
they do is somehow racist.
So, part of it is that
there is an aversion
to addressing these issues head on
and from even the procedural justice
and historical module
trainings in Stockton's,
the command college that
I was talking about,
I mean, nine out of 10 officers will say,
"Well, I don't see color. I
don't see color, I'm not racist.
Yes, that might've happened 50 years ago,
but like that's not how I do my job.
I'm color blind."
And so, when that's the premise,
it takes a lot of work and discussion
to even kind of begin to peel back
where you can begin to open
people to being receptive
to understanding these kinds
of like larger historical
and political dynamics at stake.
- Can I just add one thing to that,
which is, police are not unique.
- Right.
And I think that's important
to understand, right?
They are not singular in any way.
There are plenty people that I deal with
on a day-to-day basis at this university
who are no different from that.
It's just that the cost
of their aversion to it
is much greater, but many
of us on this Zoom call
probably have kids in school and stuff.
Think about the teachers you deal with.
We all encounter people in
various versions of that,
so, I think that piece is worth saying
and it's also an opportunity
for me to lift up
another one of our colleagues
at the Justice Collaboratory,
Jen Richardson, who's
a social psychologist
who studies this phenomenon.
It's universal, so we
should be clear about that.
- Something that's coming up in that point
about there are so many people
in so many different roles
who are participating in
racialized surveillance,
whether they're an
educator, a social worker,
even like benign roles
where they may not even be
interacting with so many people.
So, something that I am thinking about
in reference to the work
that you're doing, Elizabeth,
with police departments and
educating them on history,
I'm thinking of the local kind
of grassroots political education
that's been taking place
in cities across the U.S., so
teaching community members,
or also kind of harvesting the knowledge
and historical memory
within the communities
about the historic role of
police and state violence,
and surveillance and
how that local knowledge
has maybe a particularly
transformative role
because of the way spatially situated.
And this is a bit of a ramble,
but I'm thinking about
that spatial situation,
the work that memory can
do on the local level,
but then kind of these acute barriers,
as you've mentioned,
Tracey, at the municipal,
county, state, and federal level.
And what kind of meaning might
we make about this growth
in political education and
coinciding mobilization
amid a lot of governance barriers?
Yeah, I was just wondering
if you can comment on that a little bit.
- Well, I think just briefly,
I mean, it's a great question
and it speaks to the moment that we're in.
And it's a reminder that,
I mean, we've been talking a lot
and most of our discussion
has really been centered
on the police and law enforcement,
but that doesn't mean that like
that that's going to be the
agent for change, right?
History, and particularly Black history,
teaches us that it is about organizing,
it is about political
education, that it takes time,
that it's not like an instant thing,
and that we've got to continually
put pressure on the state
in order to bring about the
changes that we'd like to see.
So I think that's what's so
exciting about this moment
is that we just witnessed,
and this again gets to the comments
how Professor Goldsby opened
up this whole discussion,
the stakes are very clear,
they've never been higher.
We just witnessed what's being called
the largest mass movement in
U.S. history for anything,
but it was premise around
the idea of racial justice
and social justice.
And I think it's up to us
to keep this momentum going
because what history shows
us is that policymakers,
and police chiefs, and police unions,
they're not gonna make changes,
they're not gonna make any reform
out of the goodness of their
heart, it takes pressure.
And it's up to us to
keep that pressure on.
And I think, I mean, that's part
of what has been so important
about some of this moment and
the technological advances
of the last 15 years or
so, right, five years even,
because it's not as if this
police violence is new,
and it's not as if Black communities
where this police violence
happened weren't aware of it,
it's just that it has been so localized.
And now, I mean, really beginning
with Rodney King in '91,
the nation and white people in particular,
are now witness to this violence,
and the kind of onslaught of
that has continued to pace,
especially during Barack
Obama's second term
we've seen the mobilization grow.
And so, I think now that
everybody has their
camera in their pocket,
we're beginning to build this,
a kind of documentary evidence
that has outraged people
so that now most Americans,
according to polling,
do think there needs to be
some kind of policing reform.
Most Americans support the
idea of Black Lives Matter
and wanna see racial justice.
This is unprecedented.
And so, I think the public
is becoming more educated
and we need to continue that education
and keep the pressure
on, which is why, again,
I think it's really
exciting to be here at Yale
and part of the Justice
Collaboratory in this moment
because it does feel like,
and it's not gonna be easy,
it's gonna be a lot of work,
we may not see it in our lifetime,
I don't know, Tracey,
it may not fully happen
by the time you retire,
but we are beginning to
churn out something new
that hopefully we'll finally learn from
and move beyond the
lessons that we now know
of all of the failed approaches
and all of the oppressive
and repressive measures
that had shaped dynamics of inequality
and of police community
relations, historically.
- Tracey, do you wanna add anything?
- That was good.
And, yeah, I know it's not happening
before I retire, but I'm
still retiring. (laughs)
- To follow up on this
piece about time, momentum,
and unprecedented support,
and then situating, kind
of relating this moment
to what seemed like a
similarly pivotal moment
post Kerner-Commission,
Elizabeth, I wonder if based
on your wisdom as a historian
and as an activist scholar,
if you could talk a bit
about what is it gonna take
to kind of shirk that
historical path, right,
particularly of ensuring that liberals,
white liberal policymakers do not shy away
from the urgent and historically situated
demands of community members right now.
- That's another really big question.
I mean, and this has
been like my new research
has really made clear to
me the Kerner Commission
was like the biggest post-riot commission,
but in many of the cities that experienced
that kind of violence,
that they had like civil
rights commissions,
or human relations
commissions of their own,
many of which were kind of
modeled on the Kerner Commission,
all of which pointed attention
to the specific socioeconomic
conditions in various locales,
like the Kerner Commission
recognized the role of white racism,
but also like the Kerner
Commission was very limited
in terms of it's kind of
pathological and racist assumptions
about poor Black Americans,
about the nature of Black poverty,
about Black criminality
stemming from ideas
about Black criminality historically,
but really kind of taking hold
in a new and important way
following Moynihan's Report.
And having said that, the kind of impulse
after these moments of police violence
is to start a commission or
put together a task force,
and we don't necessarily need
another kind of national task force
to study the problem of inequality
and then essentially do an update
to the Kerner Commission's
recommendations, which is saying,
"We need a Marshall Plan
for American cities.
We need a different kind of investments
that would go beyond the war on poverty."
And I think having said
that, that's what's needed.
We know what's needed,
these demands have been made
and these recommendations have been made
over, and over, and over again,
now for more than a half century,
and it's time to actually do it.
And as I just said, like I'm
hopeful we're gonna do it,
it's gonna take a lot of work,
but it's also I think
that the recent election
was really humbling because we have a lot,
I mean, it's not just political education
in the communities that are
kind of like ground zero
for this kind of policing, but
it's like political education
throughout the United States,
because the fact is that Donald Trump
got the second highest number of votes
for any presidential
candidate in U.S. history,
74 million people voted for Donald Trump.
I mean, we see it now in
the Georgia runoff election,
where it's basically based on
do you want these radical
socialists and anarchists
to take over and implement
a green new deal,
and take your rights away,
and take police away,
and all of these things?
So, I mean, I think a lot of us recognize
that what it's gonna take is a
major structural intervention
and changing the tax structure,
many of the things that we've mentioned,
but the process of actually realizing that
is gonna be substantial.
So, we don't need to begin that process
by continuing to study the problem.
I do think having said that,
and Tracey and I are on-
- I was like, what are you talking about?
Why are we doing our thing?
(Tracey and Elizabeth laughing heartily)
- We are on a task force right now
at the National Academies
that's looking specifically
at racial disparities.
See, that is something that's
new, that has not been done,
there has not really been a task force
that is seeking to study
and identify specifically
the racial disparities
within the justice system.
That wasn't a objective
of the Kerner Commission,
that wasn't an objective
of any of the commissions
that I've seen or studied.
And I think one step
towards meaningful change
is really documenting the
ways in which policing
and the criminal legal
system in the United States
targets people of color
and has exacerbated racial inequality.
And so, I think centering
racism in that discussion
is a necessary way to achieve change,
but we know that what we need
is a structural transformation,
and so we need to work
towards building that
rather than continuing
to study that problem.
Racism is something that,
and again, my experience working
with police in California
demonstrates is something
that we still have a long way to go.
And I think that the, again,
the support for white extremism
that we have seen really on,
not that it ever went away,
but really on very visible
display in recent months
shows just how far we have to go
in order to become a truly
racially egalitarian nation.
- So, how do I wanna intervene?
I don't mean intervene
as in I disagree with
anything that you said,
I'd just like to say something useful
as we are getting to the
end of this conversation.
So, I think the place
that I wanna build on
is this idea of structure
and juxtapose it against
the idea of rights
which has been sort of the fundamental way
of trying to push forward
on these topics, right?
And I think, if you tie the structure
and rights conversation to
the point about federalism,
you understand the ways in which
identifying certain
outcomes that you want,
like the Kerner Commission says,
"People need all of these things," right?
Let's say we had said, "Okay,
people have rights to
those things," right?
Then the question is, how is it
that government is
actually gonna make good
on giving people the
material resources they need
for those rights, to
effectuate those rights.
And, it's interesting, Elizabeth,
that you mentioned voting
'cause I just read a book yesterday,
and draft by a law
professor Guy Charles Uriel
and his coauthor Luis Fuentes,
and when you think about
the Voting Rights Act,
you have to understand that
the United States Constitution
actually does not give people
a constitutional right to vote.
That is actually provided
at the state level.
And when you look at the ways
in which the federal
government has supported
or not supported that, on the one hand,
we see that this election
was sort of fraud
and it felt too close, and
all of those people voted
for this person that is
essentially King George,
if you read the
Declaration of Independence
as I did last night, about 80%
of the complaints against King George
actually apply to the
person who is President
of the United States right now,
which is an interesting
exercise, but in any case, right,
because we don't have a federalist,
like a national context for
effectuation of these outcomes
to which we wanna give people rights,
it basically points up the demand
for changing the structure of it, right?
That is, if we could
actually get universal voting
and made that meaningful structurally,
which, in some sense,
requires appending federalism.
I hope I'm not being too elliptical.
I'd love to share Guy's chapters with you
which makes this point very clear,
then you'd see that there's
actually a path perhaps
to achieving the things
that we have long known are necessary.
And it ends up being kind of
a procedural justice point
in a sense, because in the way
that democratic governance
works in this country,
you need a path, you need a process
for effectuation of
these substantive rights
to which people want to have access.
And people care a lot about that,
we know that from the
social psychology work,
people care about having
access to certain processes
in order to make meaning
of their role in society,
but just we also know as
just a mechanical matter,
that's how you get this done, right,
that's where power and governance meet
in terms of getting people
what they want and need.
And I hope that made sense.
- Thank you both for, I
think, that last question
just underscored how much
we need this revolution,
how much it is a reconstructive process
that requires an interdisciplinary space
like the African-American
Studies Department
that's leading this colloquium
and the Justice Collaboratory
that's doing similar work
from a policy perspective.
We are completely out of time,
and I just want to thank
you both Professor Hinton,
Professor Meares, Professor Feimster,
and Professor Goldsby for convening us.
I'm so grateful to have had the chance
to be in conversation with you today.
And I wish everybody
a healthy and safe remainder of 2020.
- I thank you so much.
- Thank you, Tracey, thank you, Gwen,
you did an amazing job.
- Yeah, thank you, thank you.
- You were wonderful, my dear.
- Thank you.
(all laughing)